now hold on it's not all uh bad news
because we have uh we have this story
from politico uh we have another story
too uh apparently mark milley says it's
possible the u.s will work with the town
oh because of isis k cool so uh so we
have that and then we also we also have
the bud administration is now
considering giving the taliban cash aid
if they uphold their international
obligations so it seems like biden's
strategy was like well
we can pay to have people there on the
ground securing the country indefinitely
or we can pay the taliban to just do
whatever as long as they do the things
we like we know how that plays out you
give the taliban cash you encourage all
the bad things they're doing because
then they're like we'll keep doing bad
things unless you give us more money
then you give them money the bad things
go down for a few months and they start
coming back and they say well maybe you
got to give us more money it's like that
trope where the guy like walks the the
private detective walks in and he's like
i need information and then he's like
you know maybe i need a little cash and
then he hands him money and the guy goes
maybe i need a little bit more and he
keeps milking as much as he can yeah you
can't do that doesn't work well when you
lose a war the loser always pays
period we lost a war therefore we pay
none of that surprises me
when you lose a war you pay money ask
england or sorry even even if you help
somebody win a war they still pay well
you can also end a war with what's
called a white peace which is where
nobody wins and nobody loses it's just
the war just stops and that's probably
what should have happened but they
surrendered
that's a different form of ending a war
that's when you give them money
i think all this comes back to our
original question that we formulated a
while back dumb or diabolical
dumb or diabolical i'm leaning dumb here
they're gonna work with the taliban and
give them cash i don't know if that's
that's i mean it could be dumb
antibiotics i just mean the entire the
entire thing is dumb the entire every
decision to go in going all the way back
to george w bush's decision to go in
there his announcement in the second
inaugural address where he says that the
american foreign policy goal is to end
tyranny across the world what that was a
radical transformation of american
foreign policy that was doomed from the
start it's representative of progressive
ideology and it has now played out over
20 years where along the way we tried to
gender studies them up in the whole
thing to make them peaceful and modern
just like us and it failed it failed to
fail to fail it's dumb dumb dumb dumb
dum all down the way what did what what
did we do back in uh let me make sure i
have the year right what was the the
cold war era in afghanistan the 19th
century yeah what who who was it that
was uh being trained and armed in the
1970s in afghanistan by the united
states some bad guys that came later to
blow us up yeah they called them the
mujahideen
yeah and the us
armed and trained them so they would
fight against the soviets and drive the
soviet union out and they did and then
later on broke off to form al-qaeda on
the taliban that al-qaeda attacks us and
then taliban takes over afghanistan and
the u.s goes oh oh no now we have to
evade iraq
i guess because saddam hussein is bad
and you know that whole thing is going
on so then we did that of course we went
to afghanistan first and so i look at
this and i'm wondering jack are they
really dumb
or is iran about to get a whole lot of
weapons high grade advanced american
weaponry because afghanistan can't
maintain their own economy already we're
seeing videos and photos of people
lining up outside of banks by the
hundreds because the economy just
stopped there's no central banker
anymore not like i like central banking
but the people who ran that place are
gone you think the taliban keep the
power on no but i'll tell you what they
can do they can call their buddies over
in iran and say we need infrastructure
help now and iran will be like we see
you got some pretty uh blackhawks over
there so what happens real quick in 10
15 or 20 years
when you've got a new isis armed with
advanced american weaponry and they're
causing problems and the older
generation is is retiring they're or
many are passing on you know we're all
you know we're going to be in our 50s
and 60s and the young generation not
remembering any of what happened says oh
no these evil people overseas are are
are you know violent and oppressive we
should stop them and the us goes uh oh
no look at all the weapons and all the
terror we have to stop them so the u.s
arms and funds the mujahideen they
become the al-qaida taliban
justification for our wars in the middle
east once again and are we on that same
track probably because we're stupid we
don't understand anything that's going
on over there we don't any understand
any of the the historical tribal
differences we don't understand all of
it now but you brought up a lot of
points just give me just a little bit of
space to get to them
i have talked to a number of experts
military experts us special forces
captains and pilots that have flown this
type of equipment that is there on the
ground who operated in theater
logisticians whose job it was to support
the aircraft in the in the helicopters
that are on the ground in afghanistan
and to a man each single one of them
told me the same thing one any of the
technology that we gave the afghanistan
army was old old stuff it was not the
latest and greatest none of it we didn't
give them the highest latest and
greatest weapon weaponry systems and
they weren't even the latest and
greatest blackhawk versions
two that china and iran have both had
access to this technology since the 80s
three that it will be impossible to
sustain and maintain this hardware in
that desert without the massive
logistical support that comes with the
united states military
so
and again i get tons of pushback on this
on twitter i don't know about any of
this stuff i'm literally talking to
people that were in theater in field who
know this equipment and know how it
works and this is what they have told me
people people often respond to us saying
that iran still uses you know captured
planes from the 70s they do because now
this is in the comparison again i've had
the same argument and i researched the
same thing the difference between iran
and afghanistan are vast
iran has is a fully formed civilization
of thousands of years
they have their own domestic commercial
aviation industry they make planes and
engines and stuff
afghanistan doesn't even have
electricity okay what differentiator is
to the west of afghanistan
now to that point as far as i understand
it and i'm not an expert so if i'm wrong
i apologize people tell me
iran shia
afghanistan sunni
how are they how they're they're they're
natural-born enemies why are they
supporting each other are they
supporting each other
i don't know so all these arguments that
i'm hearing about iran's going to help
afghanistan and we're giving them all
this equipment and whatever upon further
investigation not all of that holds up
i mean well i i don't i wouldn't say
that doesn't hold up good argument and
obviously look we're a bunch of guys on
the internet acting you're talking about
this great war and i'm sure there's some
like you know e4 or whatever it was like
he knows him so much more than we do i'm
sure but i've talked to the guys that
actually know who are in the field that
fly the things they fly the things in
afghanistan have been there and done it
and supported it it takes in order to do
a hardware overhaul on a blackhawk it
takes a year to disassemble it
before it takes two years to put it back
together oh yeah and that is just to
support it from regular flight
operations and i see they're doing
military parades and there and you know
guys by the way that that blackhawk
image of the guy hanging from it he
wasn't hanging he was in a harness and
he was waving to everybody yeah okay
they were flaunting it they weren't
killing anybody but the point is they're
just joyriding this stuff around which
means it's going to degrade even more
quickly but they don't care because they
beat us without any of that crap in the
first place you know why because they
have time and they have mountains no no
no i'm pretty sure they had f-15s and
nuclear weapons right you know joe biden
said you'd have to have that to defeat
the us clearly they did and biden's just
keeping it a secret from us because if
we found out that the taliban had
noticed we'd be real scared right indeed
or they're just mountain people with
guns mountain people with guns which is
exactly what i want to be here in the
united states and i had a friend joke
that appalachia will be the graveyard of
empires yeah uh here in the united
states wow that's a cool right the
graveyard of empires in appalachia it's
like like you know so i was i was
watching this i was reading something
about why afghanistan is just a terrible
location and it's because there's people
who who grow up there who live there who
live in the mountains and
subsist on mountain life and we try to
go in and that's the high ground it's
very difficult to occupy for people i
mean it's the altitude it's the
breathing and so there's not a lot there
it's rocky and it's just hard to hard to
hold no no great empire's been able to
do it
so i wonder if that you know then
translates to to appalachia it does
indeed it does indeed and i was just
watching the patriot the other night and
it's a historical significance aside
uh powerful movie but there's a great
line in there where mel gibson's like
you know i taught you every back trail
and cave and hideout in this region and
that's what we're going to do and that's
how we're going to use it and that's
what i've always been taught about the
american revolution is that we
ultimately won mostly because we knew
the train and we could act in a gorilla
fashion etc but look i think that's a
myth actually that that is why we won
yeah i think it wasn't because we stood
up in front of the british and just shot
more musket balls no it was because the
french intervened and britain was
strained and then
i mean the revolution went on for 20
years you know the formal declaration
happened sometime after there was
already revolution in rebellion yeah
yeah and and there was shooting and the
british empire was finally like we can't
do this anymore but uh i do think the
girl tags obviously did play a role for
sure but i think it's overstated i was
reading something about it yeah and they
were like i think it's understated how
much the french intervening was like the
french wiped out the british navy at
some point it did and they showed up
there at the end and it was really
helpful but uh to just to finish this
one thought um look if you're going to
colonize
a country
you can't just send a governor and some
army guys and hope that you're going to
change the nature of the country you
have to send families
you have to send settlers you have to
send people to build cities and create
culture and art and commerce and all
these things which is why actually
we in the united states
gained our independence is because they
had to send actual humans and families
and people to settle the united states
it wasn't just a colony in the caribbean
or in africa where we could just send a
governor and some troops and just
extract the resources that we wanted
from those countries we had to actually
send human beings to come live here and
have their lives here which is why in a
way it was so successful
that it was such a civilization that we
were like you know stories
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time